OF MY INCOME, POMPOSITY,
GROUPTHINK.
SEAN HANNITY.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT, TUCKER,
AND AS ALWAYS, THANK YOU.
ANOTHER BOMBSHELL, NEW REPORTS
SURROUNDING NEAR GOVERNOR,
ANDREW CUOMO.
HIS ASSOCIATES WAGED A SMEAR
CAMPAIGN AGAINST HIS FIRST
ACCUSER, THE FIRST OF 7 ONLY
DAYS AFTER HER ALLEGATIONS
BECAME PUBLIC.
SO, IS ANDREW CUOMO GOING TO BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE BY THAT I
BELIEVE HER CAUCUS?
WE WILL BRING YOU THAT IMPORTANT
UPDATE STRAIGHT AHEAD.
WE WILL ALSO HAVE FULL COVERAGE
OF THE GROWING CRISIS, IT IS A
CRISIS, IT’S REAL, ON OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER
WHERE 4 SUSPECTED TERRORISTS
HAVE BEEN --
TRYING TO CROSS ILLEGALLY INTO
THIS COUNTRY INCLUDING THREE
INDIVIDUALS FROM YEMEN.
KEVIN McCARTHY WILL BE HERE
WITH AN UPDATE AND UNLIKE
JOE BIDEN, WHO DOESN’T EVEN SEEM
TO REALIZE THERE IS A CRISIS,
McCARTHY ACTUALLY VISITED THE
BORDER.
WE WILL SHOW YOU SOME OF THAT
VIDEOTAPE.
BUT FIRST, WITH RAZOR-THIN
MAJORITIES IN THE U.S. HOUSE AND
THE SENATE, NOW DEMOCRATS ARE
ATTEMPTING TO IMPLEMENT WHAT
WILL BE THE SINGLE LARGEST
BIGGEST POWER GRAB IN MODERN
AMERICAN POLITICAL HISTORY.
AS WE SPEAK, THERE IS NOW A FULL
COURT PRESS TO ABOLISH THE
LEGISLATIVE FILIBUSTER IN THE
UNITED STATES SENATE.
WHAT JOE BIDEN JUST SAID EARLIER
TONIGHT IN AN INTERVIEW FOR ABC.
>> I KNOW YOU HAVE BEEN
RELUCTANT TO DO AWAY WITH THE
FILIBUSTER.
AREN’T YOU GOING TO HAVE ISSUES
BETWEEN OBSERVING IT AND
ADVANCING YOUR AGENDA CUSTOMER
>> YES, AND HERE IS THE CHOICE.
WE WILL HAVE TO DO WHAT WE FIRST
DID WHEN I FIRST GOT TO THE
SENATE AND BACK IN THE OLD DAYS.
THAT IS THAT A FILIBUSTER, YOU
HAVE TO STAND UP AND COMMAND THE
FLOOR.
AND YOU’VE GOT TO KEEP TALKING.
NO ONE CAN SAY --
ONCE YOU STOP TALKING AND YOU’VE
LOST THAT AND SOMEONE CAN MOVE
IN AND SAY --
YOU GOT TO WORK FOR THE
FILIBUSTER.
BRINGING BACK THE TALKING
>> I AM HERE THAT’S WHAT IT’S
SUPPOSED TO BE.
>> Sean: NOW THAT JOE WANTS TO
MAKE IT HARDER FOR THE
FILIBUSTER, MOST EMIGRANTS WANT
TO DO AWAY WITH IT COMPLETELY.
THEY KNOW THAT THE SOCIALIST
UTOPIA VISION THAT THEY HAVE,
THEY KNOW THEIR RADICAL BILLS
WILL NEVER GET THE 60 VOTES
NEEDED TO CLEAR THE FILIBUSTER
FOR THE SENATE.
SO NOW THEY WILL JUST CHANGE THE
RULES.
ACCORDING TO THE TOP DEMOCRATS,
WE ARE NOW HEARING TONIGHT THAT
THE FILIBUSTER IS INCREDIBLY --
ARE NOW THE DEMOCRATS ARE IN
CHARGE AND IT MUST BE ABOLISHED
AND ABOLISHED IMMEDIATELY SO
THEY CAN JUST PASS ANYTHING AND
EVERYTHING THEY WANT AND RAM IT
DOWN THE COUNTRY’S THROAT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WHAT ABOUT THAT NUCLEAR
OPTION DOING AWAY WITH THE
FILIBUSTER?
>> WELCOME I CAN TELL YOU THAT
WOULD BE THE END OF THE SENATE.
>> TODAY’S THE BUSTER IS OFTEN
USED TO PREVENT THE SENATE FROM
EVEN STARTING IMPORTANT
IDEAS.
IT HAS BECOME THE DEATH OF
DEMOCRACY.
>> I SAID LET’S NOT DO THE
SUPREME COURT.
WE SHOULD HAVE 60 VOTES, WHICH
WE STILL DO, BECAUSE WE SHOULD
GET BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
>> WE HOPE OUR REPUBLICAN
COLLEAGUES WILL WORK WITH US TO
PRODUCE THAT CHANGE.
WE WILL TRY TO GET THEM TO WORK
WITH US.
BUT IF NOT, WE WILL PUT OUR
HEADS TOGETHER AND FIGURE OUT
HOW TO GO AND EVERY THING IS ON
THE TABLE.
>> THE POINT THAT WE HAVE LESS
THAN 60 VOTES IN PLACE, MITCH
McCONNELL CHANGE THAT.
I WOULD PREFER TO BRING IT BACK
HERE WE ARE WHERE WE ARE AND NOW
I DON’T THINK ANYONE IS GOING TO
WANT TO --
>> I THINK WE HAVE TOO MUCH WE
HAVE TO DO FOR THIS COUNTRY.
>> Sean: AMAZING WHAT A COUPLE
OF YEARS WILL DO WHEN YOU’RE IN
CHARGE.
HERE’S WHAT YOU NEED TO KNOW
ABOUT THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
IT IS FILLED WITH NOW THE MOST
RADICAL FAR LEFT INDIVIDUALS OF
ANY MAJOR POLITICAL PARTY IN
MODERN HISTORY.
THE ONLY REAL PRINCIPLE IS POWER
OVER EVERYTHING COME OVER THE
CONSTITUTION, OVER THE
BILL OF RIGHTS, OVER THE RULE OF
LAW, OVER BASIC FAIRNESS AND
JUSTICE.
THEY WANT ONE PARTY RULE.
THEY WANT IT IN PERPETUITY
FOREVER AND EVER.
NOW THEY PLAN TO ACHIEVE THIS
GOAL THAT CONSISTS OF THREE MAIN
PARTS.
NUMBER ONE, KILL THE FILIBUSTER.
NUMBER TWO, PASS HR ONE WITH A
SIMPLE MAJORITY.
THAT’S THE BILL THAT WOULD
EXPAND VOTING TO CONVICTED
FELONS, ELIMINATE ALL VOTER I.D.
WHATSOEVER LAWS, AUTOMATICALLY
REGISTER EVERYBODY IN THE
COUNTRY AND EXPAND MASSIVELY
MALE AND VOTING.
IN OTHER WORDS, HR ONE CREATES
AN ELECTION SYSTEM WAY MORE
SUSCEPTIBLE TO FRAUD AND ABUSE
AND BALLOT HARVESTING, A
DREAMLIKE SCENARIO FOR THIS
MODERN POWER-HUNGRY DEMOCRATIC
SOCIALIST PARTY.
MAKE NO MISTAKE, THE BILL IS NOT
ONLY NONCONSTITUTIONAL, IT
FEDERALIZE IS THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF ELECTIONS.
IT ASSERTS THE STATED POWER
GIVEN TO STATE LEGISLATURES AND
IT IS RESERVED FOR THEM AND THAT
IS WHERE STEP THREE COMES INTO
PLAY.
THEY WANT TO COURT PACKING.
AS WE PROTECTED, TOP DEMOCRATS
NOW WANT TO EXPAND AND IMPACT
THE U.S. SUPREME COURT AND LOWER
COURTS WITH FAR LEFT ACTIVISTS
WHO WILL RUBBER-STAMP THEIR
RADICAL AGENDA.
LATE JANUARY, LESS THAN A WEEK
AFTER GETTING SWORN IN,
JOE BIDEN STARTED A PETITION TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO GET ALL OF
THAT DONE.
THAT WOULD BE A DOOMSDAY
SCENARIO NOT JUST FOR THE
G.O.P., FOR BUT FOR THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY.
ONE-PARTY DEMOCRATIC RULE ALWAYS
ENDS WITH THE SAME RESULTS.
HIGHER TAXES, MORE POVERTY,
RAMPANT CORRUPTION, BROKEN
PROMISES, OH, AND THEY WANT TO
MAKE D.C. AND PUERTO RICO A
STATE, SO THEY THINK THEY WILL
HAVE 4 DEMOCRATIC SENATORS ADDED
IN PERPETUITY.
LOOK AT NEW YORK.
LOOK AT NEW JERSEY.
LOOK AT ILLINOIS PEER LOOK AT
CALIFORNIA.
THAT IS WHAT THEY WANT AMERICA
TO LOOK LIKE.
UNFORTUNATELY, WE COME TO YOU,
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, YOU CAN
STOP THIS FROM HAPPENING
ESPECIALLY IF YOU LIVE IN
WEST VIRGINIA OR ARIZONA.
THOSE TWO PEOPLE RIGHT THERE, TO
QUOTE ON A CHRONIC SENATORS
AGAIN, ENDING THE LEGISLATIVE
FILIBUSTER.
THOSE TWO SENATORS FOLLOW
THROUGH WITH THEIR PROMISES THAT
THE FILIBUSTER WILL REMAIN IN
PLACE, THE VERY ONE DEMOCRATS
WERE DEMANDING ALSO WOULD
DESTROY THE SENATE.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY, JOE MANCHIN
LOOKS LIKE HE IS BEGINNING TO
BUCKLE WHEN PRESSURED BY
CHUCK SCHUMER.
SO, IF YOU ARE FROM
WEST VIRGINIA AND ARIZONA, YOU
MIGHT WANT TO CALL, YOU MIGHT
WANT TO WRITE, YOU WANT TO
EMAIL.
I SUGGEST YOU BE POLITE TO LET
YOUR VOICES BE HEARD.
ONCE THAT FILIBUSTER IS GONE,
THE PARTY THAT PUTS POWER OVER